to the two of you with a British prism
let's first speak of mr. Corbin we
covered that last week is it simple John
to say that Corbin is the same as lapad
is the same is what we observe in the
United States I think a lot of copán is
about anger if you look at all the young
people who rushed out to vote to Corbin
even if some of them knew that he's
slightly mad they still thought he's
genuine and it's some the same approach
that people see when they listen to
Donald Trump is they think that Donald
Trump even when he's being rude is he's
speaking his mind he's telling it like
it what it is exactly i see that with
you see that lapel you see it would
trump the authenticity question this is
where it Adrian what you know what
should these leaders do they have golden
opportunity particularly leaders on the
left right now the anti-austerity
leaders what what should they do with
that none of them seem to be coming up
with a platform that's actually
resonating policy well well well
something like Corbin really wants to
reinvent the 1970s which I don't think
is the best way of going in the age of
in the age of the Internet I don't think
Corbett is going to become a significant
leader of a written he's not gonna
become Prime Minister I think of much
more interesting thing that's going on
is what's happening in Spain at the
moment with perdimos I think bday miss
has a real chance of winning the
election in December they really are
hardline very disciplined lefties and
that would be a real alien they have the
distraction over the weekend of the
Catalonia referendum again it is well
Francine I was taken this week or late
last week by the drama on your house of
commons as we saw well dressed but we
would call Wall Streeters dark suits and
ties and there was the tweed one looking
disheveled and rumpled I mean it was a
stark visual contrast it is and it's a
visual contrast that we're also seeing
in France Tom with the Mahina pen that
you know tries to roll up her sleeves
being one of the people of course to the
extreme right are not the extreme left
like we've seen here in the UK John when
you look at politics around the world in
Europe when you look at Donald Trump and
you wonder whether he's stoppable or not
are we losing moderate politicians and
is it just a short phase or is there
actually a worry that with the refugee
crisis with inequality widening it will
see more extreme politicians around the
world well what's interesting is there
was a good piece by Tony Blair of all
people a couple
weeks ago in The Guardian where he made
the point that it's really odd they are
moderate politics moderate politicians
when they stand in front of these people
and say no don't vote for them they have
no programs really at the moment they
have no traction and what's been
happening so far is that when it
actually comes to the real polls no
one's gone for them but you've had
Tsaritsa in Greece you've got podemos in
Spain you've got the hint of something
and actually the way you the way you
describe marine lepen is very true my
parents law used to live in the very
rural France the lady at show more who
used to sell me my newspaper she looked
dressed and sounded like marine lepen
and she associates with the with the
heart of France rather than the elite in
Paris the two of you and I'd be remiss
if I not to bring this up Adrian and
John wrote a terrific book called God is
back and you talked about the acids of
modernity and then here we have the Pope
defeating the modernity in his trip here
is trip to Cuba and such what do you
mean Adrian by the acids of modernity
the classic view of modernity is that it
destroys faith it destroys religion that
you all become secular that's the acids
of modernity reason destroys faith and
what we argued in that book is reason
doesn't destroy faith quite often
modernity technological innovation
creates a desire for for faith for some
some reassurance in a very disruptive
world we see journey with the Book of
Common Prayer coming out of the English
experience all of the turmoil of 1928 in
America 1968 and then a 79 read you
what's the next redo within this Pope
for Christianity what do you see with
God is back whether Muslim Jewish or
Christianity what's the next shift well
I think they're in different phases I
think the Muslim world is still in
something much more similar to the era
of the Book of Common Prayer when it was
first invented you see exactly the same
thing happening the Muslim world or
somewhat similar to what happened during
the great Wars of Religion in Europe
when actually nation states began to
evolve partly because religion was
tearing things apart you Joe well good
we saw yesterday in the bloomberg poll
that people are generally very unhappy
with the political system in the United
States we see that often but you say
they don't need to be there is a better
way what is that
I think what's interesting is that for
all the despair about politics you have
to imagine in the end and that was the
point of the book on the fourth
revolution in government people people
in the end will start to change
government it seems impossible for me to
imagine you've got google in the
headlines that the same revolutions have
swept through the private sector what
happened in the public sector and the
other thing which happens is competition
the reason why the West got ahead of
China was because we competed because
France competed with Britain competed
with Germany we kept on pushing each
other forward even creating welfare
states partly in response to the rise of
Germany the West has always been really
good at government now it faces China
which is really trying to take it over
Germany that gives us right to our theme
and of course the pageantry will see
this morning